Timur is the same like you're touchy
wasn't the nibbler 31 is exactly the
same you're trying to work on your
principles of IP and cook you okay so as
I'm doing the first wallah to take the
first one
this is resistant he's got that line
there you see that you guys see that
it's not a two-on-one that's not ice
so look what I do here you see that
gluteus so I tied that one then I passed
it and as I pass it I'm not going to
lift this thing are you going to disturb
this balance I'm looking for the Kazushi
angle you see how I did that
then his angle is over here see then I
move out of that way see what's
happening watch all this later
see so as I start to do that when I
bridge I'm not lifting him up I'm moving
myself in harmony with his chest so that
he falls and we changed positions okay
so I'm here we changed position we think
and I'm solving him
and I go then the draw
[Music]
so Chris ushi ie boom hardening drill n
nothing changes so up not going to move
him I'm going to stop him from coming
forward so when I go up for a Kazushi
this hand doesn't push I just don't let
him come up to me and I move me find the
open space moved in the open space find
the contact point so I'm not here and
I'm going to try the shrimp under this
we're going to trace the mission go
exactly chest to chest you see that you
can move around
[Music]
so one
don't let them move forward wheezy
at this level you're trying to be as
water like is possible fluid next basic
same thing
find your principle one fluid disturbia
back